china's appetite for energy is enormous
the country consumes about a quarter of
the world's energy supply 35 percent
more than the us annually
its energy needs have more than tripled
since the year 2000
that consumption has helped to fuel
astonishing growth but it's come at a
cost
china is the world's largest greenhouse
gas emitter there is no way to tackle
climate change unless china reduces its
emissions to net zero
the country's reliance on fossil fuels
is also a hindrance to its own growth
and the well-being of its citizens
china is not energy secure it has a
massive import bill for things like oil
and gas it has a long-standing pollution
problem and it is also prone to outages
that severely hamper industry
all this has led the world's biggest
polluter to take steps towards a radical
transformation
president xi jinping outlined his plans
to make china carbon neutral by 2060.
covert 19 reminds us that humankind
should launch green revolution and move
faster to create a green way of
development
china's high level goals are that within
this decade it's going to peak its
carbon emissions
and then it's going to go to net zero by
2060 so that gives it approximately 40
years to do something that no country
has achieved let alone something like
the size of china
as the world starts to turn away from
fossil fuels china is positioning itself
as the king of clean energy not only
transforming its own energy system but
also building a supply chain that could
leave the world uncomfortably dependent
on china for its energy needs
china has really expanded its grip so
it's the processing it's the
manufacturing it's all the way down to
your evs and your battery packs how the
west deals with that they're going to
have to be a bit creative what china
plans to accomplish by 2030 could
determine the shape of the global energy
system of the future
at the end of the last century china was
on the cusp of an economic revolution
in 1990 its gdp was only six percent
that of the us
and his energy use was only 34 percent
but the economic reforms of the 80s and
90s started the process of privatizing
industry and opening up to trade with
the rest of the world by the time it
joined the world trade organization in
2001 china was well on its way to
becoming the world's factory with
booming energy needs to match
the history of it is really
dramatic i think just the condensation
really china is doing industrial
revolution 100 years after that all of
that in a very concentrated period of
time
so what we saw was obviously dramatic
change in terms of energy consumption
and there were power crunches in the
early years where really the system was
still trying to cope dramatic addition
of coal-fired plants in particular to
deal with that
from a climate perspective the position
was well you had your turn now it's our
turn when you were growing you as the
west there was no question of what
carbon was doing you did whatever you
wanted now it's our turn that really
changed in 2008 2009 and that coincides
with an awareness of air pollution
in beijing which is facing another
smoggy day some environmentalists say it
is the worst air on record
beijing was famously the most polluted
city in the world for almost a decade
it also became very clear to its
leadership that that kind of growth will
be unsustainable not just from a fact of
putting out a lot of emissions but from
a fact that much of the fossil fuel
consumption for example oil and natural
gas will have to be imported
and that's something china wanted to
walk away from
so starting about 2010 china committed
to increase its deployment of renewables
china like like many other places in the
world was faced with initially very
non-competitive on a cost basis
economics uh for for solar projects for
wind projects
and being able to subsidize the
manufacture of the key components
ensuring the power that they sell has an
attractive rate all these things china
has done very very well you push the
market into existence and then you're
able to pull back with some of the
policy mandates because now it just
makes good economic sense
china's investments in renewables helped
drive astonishing price drops across the
industry leading to record levels of new
wind and solar installations all over
the world in recent years
last year wind and solar generated more
than 10 of the world's electricity
still renewables only make up a tiny
fraction of china's energy mix today
china is overwhelmingly dependent on
fossil fuels at the moment and within
that if you look at power generation
it's overwhelmingly coal roughly 60
percent
wind biomass
solar remain a much much smaller
fraction
there was pressure building up on china
for quite a few years that china needs
to do more to cut emissions
and that finally sort of came together
in 2015
at the paris agreement when china agreed
to sign it alongside the u.s and pretty
much every country on the planet that
bit of diplomacy was crucial to take
china to the next stage which is when in
2020 it declared that it will set a net
zero goal
and in a way it was a coup for china
because
it set that goal even before the u.s
could have done so
china's decarbonization plan ramps up
gradually with fossil fuel emissions
increasing for a few years before
peaking in 2030. from there they've
given themselves another three decades
to get to net zero with 80 of energy
coming from carbon free sources by 2060
getting there will be a massive
undertaking and it starts with renewable
mega projects on a scale seen nowhere
else on earth
so late in 2021 we took a reporting trip
to qinghai
in western china
it's quite wind swept it's it's a very
sunny part of the world
very low population density
we went to a facility
that was spread out over 600 square
kilometers about the size of singapore
foreign in that facility you know they
have a hydro dam
they've got a massive solar build up and
they're adding uh wind installations as
well
when all of that is up and running it's
going to be producing nearly 20
gigawatts of energy
it's enough to cover the power needs at
any given time for israel for example
by 2030 china plans to scale up to 1.2
terawatts of wind and solar capacity
enough to meet all of the us's
electricity needs today
but it's not enough just to generate
that power
getting the power where it needs to go
is a mega project in itself
um
in order to ship all that electricity um
china has basically built this huge
network of ultra high voltage power
lines
and they're designed to get all of this
energy from the west to where it's
needed
in the population and industrial centers
of the east
power lines might seem like a mundane
piece of infrastructure but they're
actually a crucial piece of the
decarbonization puzzle
a conventional ac power cable loses a
lot of electricity over the course of
hundreds of miles hence the need for
these specialized direct current lines
what they do is they reduce the wastage
that may happen on the way to transport
this electricity
there are only two countries in the
world where these cables are operating
china and brazil
has two of those cables china has
25.
by far in a way china is uh is
absolutely the leader on this
and the amount of money that you're
talking about i mean it's hundreds of
billions of dollars that they're going
to be spending on this incoming decades
as china goes towards a net zero goal
its leadership has recognized that there
is no way china can meet those goals
without having what's called firm clean
power the idea of firm clean power is
that you're able to generate carbon free
electricity when you want it rather than
relying on when the sun shines or the
wind blows
nuclear power satisfies those conditions
quite well in most countries the nuclear
industry is struggling facing huge
upfront costs regulatory hurdles and
negative public opinion
still it is a carbon-free source of
reliable power and many environmental
advocates see it as a key to the green
transition as does china's leadership
china plans to build
150 new reactors in the next 15 years
which is more than what the entire world
has built in the last 35 years
nuclear isn't seen as controversial in
china or at least we don't know if it is
it's not clear whether china china's own
population supports it or opposes it
because they're not allowed to protest
and show their opposition to a certain
technology
that still leaves the difficult
economics of nuclear the high upfront
cost of building new reactors
here too china may have unique
advantages
one thing that we all know china really
excels at doing is building huge
infrastructure quickly
after decades of building bridges and
skyscrapers and high speed rail and
ultra high voltage lines like every
super massive industrial project that
china has built that know-how goes into
also building nuclear power plants
when you build projects consistently on
schedule and on budget you actually get
to realize
the benefits that were imagined back
when the project was being planned like
stable low cost electricity at a certain
rate at a certain production cost
china's efforts to decarbonize are
likely to have many positive effects on
its domestic energy supply
but that's not the only reason china has
gone all in on clean energy
china certainly wants to meet a net zero
goal
but it also wants to be a country that
is making a lot of money exporting the
technologies that will clean up the
energy system globally
china is incredibly important when we
think about the supply chain for green
technology in general the green economy
whether that's solar panels or turbines
or the elements that you'll need to
process along the way incredibly
significant
china basically accounts for something
like 75
of the world's supply chain for solar
anything that you're going to do
in the states or in europe i mean at
some point chinese companies will have
been involved in this
that dependence on china has lately been
a source of strain last year covid
related production issues in china
caused the price of solar panels to rise
for the first time in decades
and some companies have pledged to take
their business elsewhere due to reports
of human rights abuses in the majority
uiga province of xinjiang which produces
most of the world's polysilicon a key
material in the manufacturing of solar
panels
obviously there have been
accusations in the west
that the uyghurs
are subject to forced labour
the industry and the chinese government
have denied this
some in the west are also concerned
about china's dominance over the
materials needed to make lithium-ion
batteries
cobalt for example is a scarce mineral
produced mainly in the democratic
republic of congo where china has
brought up most of the supply
the congolese government has recently
pushed back against those efforts
alleging poor working conditions and
unpaid debts by a chinese mining company
but the majority of cobalt producing
mines there are still at least part
chinese owned
crucially what china has done is it's
also made
the processing of these
metals into the chemicals that
eventually go into batteries and almost
monopoly
the processing capabilities of china
outstrip those of all the rest of the
world combined
i think any kind of excessive dependency
is problematic and energy dependency is
no different think about europe europe's
dependency on russia for gas how
problematic
that has been so if we're going to have
that the west as dependent on china for
renewable energy for green economy
ingredients it is not going to be a
healthy situation
[Music]
my instinct is that these things are not
done for a nefarious purpose right to
dominate the supply chain in a way that
is disadvantageous to to another country
but
you know that the primary consideration
is what is good for for china
i mean remember we're coming from a
period of not so long ago late 90s early
2000s when china had rolling blackouts
all the time and we've got all this
investment into making sure it can't
happen again
from the way people talk about it here
they they believe in the mission and the
mission is
stable secure energy for the chinese
people
electricity rationing is being imposed
in more than half of china's provinces
power shortages are are still on ongoing
uh i think we've got a count of 20
provinces uh where there are electricity
curbs
recently china has been having
flashbacks to the bad old days of
blackouts and power rationing
a sudden spike in the price of coal led
to widespread power shortages leaving
the government little choice but to
ration electricity and ramp up coal
production
it's indicative of a major flaw in
china's decarbonisation plan even as
they add world historic levels of
renewables they largely cancel out those
gains with new fossil fuel additions
and so this is the central challenge
because as your economy grows and even
as you add all of this renewable
capacity
you still need
to make sure that the coal supply is
flowing in order to keep the lights on
that's going to be the big challenge for
policy makers
even china's world leading investments
in carbon free energy may not get them
to their targets on time but beijing has
recognized that the economic political
and environmental rationales for clean
energy now vastly outweigh the costs
when it comes to the 2060 neutrality
target and obviously china's a long way
off and it's a huge huge audacious
target
the people that are the top leaders that
are planning it out right now they
probably won't even be around to see it
right
will they make it
i don't know it's it's a huge huge goal
but they believe they're gonna make it
what i can tell you is they're certainly
gonna try and they're certainly gonna
spend a lot of money trying to get there
you